[Music]
so you're vacationing in Zambia huh
mm-hmm let me guess you're from LA New
York yes I take it mr. Conrad won't be
joining us
two days ago he told me that our
marriage was over Oh two hours ago I
landed here on what was supposed to be
our second honeymoon by myself a lot of
people come here to get lost so they
could be found again thank you Yoda oh
you're coming on this too
yep Terra Collinsworth in case you want
to write my name down on a complaint
form
oh yeah the pilot we're flying over the
largest game reserve in Africa hang on
gonna make a stop stay in the plane hook
him back
poachers toka mama for tusks we don't do
some to help that baby we built in two
days I want to help didn't see that one
coming house first well I took a little
detour it's gonna be okay
it'll be touch and go for a while but we
will do our best I'm in this place
surrounded by wild animals hey New York
oh sorry
um you are coming home right this year
it's gonna be Christmas in Africa what
is Christmas in Africa well I can't
speak for the whole continent but here
at the Elephant Orphanage they celebrate
all week and there is no shopping
involved I'm really starting to worry
now I've got to go back home and I don't
know what I'm supposed to do with myself
maybe you're doing it here this is how
its thoughts we meet an elephant and so
begins the relationship of a lifetime
take good care of my elephant elephant
he and I were just friends
since you didn't get to go and your
fancy five-star Safari let me take you
on one with little stars like three I
get more like - I haven't seen you did
someone in a long time if I have learned
anything it's to not get too attached
never meant to stay this long you're
falling in love huh
with Africa you know what that is what
this will tell that is definitely not a
South African mistletoe
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]